PROFESSOR: OK, so the
last topic for the class
is interpretability.
As you know, the modern
machine learning models
are justifiably reputed to be
very difficult to understand.
So if I give you something
like the GPT2 model, which
we talked about in natural
language processing,
and I tell you that it
has 1.5 billion parameters
and then you say,
why is it working?
Clearly the answer
is not because
these particular parameters
have these particular values.
There is no way to
understand that.
And so the topic
today is something
that we raised a little
bit in the lecture
on fairness, where
one of the issues
there was also that if you
can't understand the model
you can't tell if the model
has baked-in prejudices
by examining it.
And so today we're going to
look at different methods
that people have
developed to try
to overcome this problem
of inscrutable models.
So there is a very
interesting bit of history.
How many of you know
of George Miller's 7
plus or minus 2 result?
Only a few.
So Miller was a psychologist at
Harvard, I think, in the 1950s.
And he wrote this paper in 1956
called "The Magical Number 7
Plus or Minus 2--
Some Limits On Our Capacity
for Processing Information."
It's quite an interesting paper.
So he started off with
something that I had forgotten.
I read this paper
many, many years ago.
And I'd forgotten that he
starts off with the question
of how many different
things can you sense?
How many different levels
of things can you sense?
So if I put headphones
on you and I
ask you to tell
me on a scale of 1
to n how loud is the sound that
I'm playing in your headphone,
it turns out people get confused
when you get beyond about five,
six, seven different
levels of intensity.
And similarly, if I give
you a bunch of colors
and I ask you to tell me
where the boundaries are
between different
colors, people seem
to come up with 7 plus or
minus 2 as the number of colors
that they can distinguish.
And so there is a long
psychological literature
of this.
And then Miller went
on to do experiments
where he asked people to
memorize lists of things.
And what he
discovered is, again,
that you could memorize
a list of about 7
plus or minus 2 things.
And beyond that, you couldn't
remember the list anymore.
So this tells us something
about the cognitive capacity
of the human mind.
And it suggests that if I
give you an explanation that
has 20 things in it,
you're unlikely to be
able to fathom it because
you can't keep all the moving
parts in your mind at one time.
Now, it's a tricky result,
because he does point out
even in 1956 that if you chunk
things into bigger chunks,
you can remember seven of those,
even if they're much bigger.
And so people who are very
good at memorizing things,
for example, make up patterns.
And they remember
those patterns,
which then allow them
to actually remember
more primitive objects.
So you know-- and we
still don't really
understand how memory works.
But this is just an
interesting observation,
and I think plays
into the question
of how do you explain things
in a complicated model?
Because it suggests
that you can't explain
too many different
things because people
won't understand what
you're talking about.
OK.
So what leads to complex models?
Well, as I say,
overfitting certainly
leads to complex models.
I remember in the
1970s when we started
working on expert
systems in healthcare,
I made a very bad faux pas.
I went to the first
joint conference
between statisticians and
artificial intelligence
researchers.
And the statisticians were
all about understanding
the variance and understanding
statistical significance and so
on.
And I was all about trying to
model details of what was going
on in an individual patient.
And in some discussion after my
talk, somebody challenged me.
And I said, well, what
we AI people are really
doing is fitting
what you guys think
is the noise,
because we're trying
to make a lot more detailed
refinements in our theories
and our models than what the
typical statistical model does.
And of course, I was roundly
booed out of the hall.
And people shunned me for
the rest of the conference
because I had done
something really stupid
to admit that I
was fitting noise.
And of course, I
didn't really believe
that I was fitting noise.
I believed that
what I was fitting
was what the average
statistician just
chalks up to noise.
And we're interested in more
details of the mechanisms.
So overfitting we
have a pretty good
handle on by regularization.
So you can-- you
know, you've seen
lots of examples
of regularization
throughout the course.
And people keep coming up
with interesting ideas for how
to apply regularization in order
to simplify models or make them
fit some preconception
of what the model ought
to look like before you
start learning it from data.
But the problem is
that there really
is true complexity
to these models,
whether or not
you're fitting noise.
There's-- the world is
a complicated place.
Human beings were not designed.
They evolved.
And so there's all kinds
of bizarre stuff left over
from our evolutionary heritage.
And so it is just complex.
It's hard to understand
in a simple way
how to make predictions that
are useful when the world really
is complex.
So what do we do in order
to try to deal with this?
Well, one approach
is to make up what
I call just-so stories that give
a simplified explanation of how
a complicated thing
actually works.
So how many of you
have read these stories
when you were a kid?
Nobody?
My God.
OK.
Must be a generational thing.
So Rudyard Kipling
was a famous author.
And he wrote the series
of just-so stories, things
like How the Lion Got His
Mane and How the Camel Got
His Hump and so on.
And of course, they're
all total bull, right?
I mean, it's not a Darwinian
evolutionary explanation
of why male lions have manes.
It's just some made up story.
But they're really cute stories.
And I enjoyed them as a kid.
And maybe you would have,
too, if your parents
had read them to you.
So I mean, I use this
as a kind of pejorative
because what the
people who follow
this line of investigation
do is they take
some very complicated model.
They make a local
approximation to it that says,
this is not an approximation
to the entire model,
but it's an approximation
to the model in the vicinity
of a particular case.
And then they explain
that simplified model.
And I'll show you
some examples of that
through the lecture today.
And the other approach
which I'll also
show you some examples
of is that you simply
trade off somewhat lower
performance for a simple--
a model that's simple enough
to be able to explain.
So things like decision
trees and logistic regression
and so on typically
don't perform quite
as well as the best, most
sophisticated models,
although you've seen plenty
of examples in this class
where, in fact, they
do perform quite well
and where they're
not outperformed
by the fancy models.
But in general, you
can do a little better
by tweaking a fancy model.
But then it becomes
incomprehensible.
And so people are
willing to say,
OK, I'm going to give up
1% or 2% in performance
in order to have a model
that I can really understand.
And the reason it makes sense
is because these models are not
self-executing.
They're typically used as
advice for some human being
who makes ultimate decisions.
Your surgeon is
not going to look
at one of these
models that says,
take out the guy's left
kidney and say, OK, I guess.
They're going to go, well,
does that make sense?
And in order to answer
the question of,
does that make sense?
It really helps to know
what the model is--
what the model's
recommendation is based on.
What is its internal logic?
And so even an approximation
to that is useful.
So the need for trust, clinical
adoption of ML models--
there are two
approaches in this paper
that I'm going to talk
about where they say, OK,
what you'd like to do is to look
at case-specific predictions.
So there is a particular
patient in a particular state
and you want to understand
what the model is
saying about that patient.
And then you also want to
have confidence in the model
overall.
And so you'd like to be able to
have an explanatory capability
that says, here are some
interesting representative
cases.
And here's how the
model views them.
Look through them and
decide whether you
agree with the approach
that this model is taking.
Now, remember my critique of
randomized controlled trials
that people do these trials.
They choose the simplest cases,
the smallest number of patients
that they need in order to
reach statistical significance,
the shortest amount of
follow-up time, et cetera.
And then the results
of those trials
are applied to very
different populations.
So Davids talked
about the cohort shift
as a generalization
of that idea.
But the same thing happens in
these machine learning models
that you train on
some set of data.
The typical
publication will then
test on some held-out
subset of the same data.
But that's not a very
accurate representation
of the real world.
If you then try to apply that
model to data from a totally
different source,
the chances are
you will have specialized
it in some way
that you don't appreciate.
And the results
that you get are not
as good as what you got
on the held-out test data
because it's more heterogeneous.
I think I mentioned
that Jeff Drazen,
the editor-in-chief of
the New England Journal,
had a meeting about a year ago
in which he was arguing that
the journal shouldn't ever
publish a research study unless
it's been validated on
two independent data sets
because he's tired of publishing
studies that wind up getting
retracted because--
not because of any overt
badness on the part
of the investigators.
They've done exactly
the kinds of things
that you've learned how
to do in this class.
But when they go
to apply that model
to a different
population, it just
doesn't work nearly
as well as it
did in the published version.
And of course, there
are all the publication
bias issues about if 50 of
us do the same experiment
and by random chance some
of us are going to get
better results than others.
And those are the
ones that are going
to get published
because the people who
got poor results don't have
anything interesting to report.
And so there's that whole
issue of publication bias,
which is another serious one.
OK.
So I wanted to just spend
a minute to say, you know,
explanation is not a new idea.
So in the expert
systems era that we
talked about a little bit in
one of our earlier classes,
we talked about the idea
that we would take medical--
human medical experts
and debrief them of what
they knew and then try to encode
those in patterns or in rules
or in various ways in a
computer program in order
to reproduce their behavior.
So Mycin was one
of those programs--
[INAUDIBLE] PhD
thesis-- in 1975.
And they published
this nice paper
that was about explanation and
rule acquisition capabilities
of the Mycin system.
And as an illustration,
they gave some examples
of what you could
do with the system.
So rules, they argued,
were quite understandable
because they say if a bunch
of conditions, then you
can draw the
following conclusion.
So given that,
you can say, well,
when the program
comes back and says,
in light of the site from
which the culture was obtained
and the method of
collection, do you
feel that a significant number
of organism 1 were detected--
were obtained?
In other words, if you took
a sample from somebody's body
and you're looking
for an infection,
do you think you got enough
organisms in that sample?
And the user says, well, why
are you asking me this question?
And the answer in terms of the
rules that the system works by
is pretty good.
It says it's
important to find out
whether there's therapeutically
significant disease associated
with this occurrence
of organism 1.
We've already established
that the culture is not
one of those that
are normally sterile
and the method of
collection is sterile.
Therefore, if the
organism has been observed
in significant
numbers, then there's
strongly suggestive evidence
that there's therapeutically
significant disease associated
with this occurrence
of the organism.
So if you find bugs in a
place carefully collected,
then that suggests
that you ought
to probably treat this patient
if there are were bunch of--
enough bugs there.
And there's also strongly
suggestive evidence
that the organism is
not a contaminant,
because the collection
method was sterile.
And you can go on with this and
you can say, well, why that?
So why that question?
And it traces back in its
evolution of these rules
and it says, well,
in order to find out
the locus of
infection, it's already
been established that the
site of the culture is known.
The number of days since
the specimen was obtained
is less than 7.
Therefore, there
is therapeutically
significant disease associated
with this occurrence
of the organism.
So there's some rule that
says if you've got bugs
and it happened within
the last seven days,
the patient probably really
does have an infection.
And I mean, I've got a
lot of examples of this.
But you can keep going why.
You know, this is
the two-year-old.
But why, daddy?
But why?
Well, why is it important to
find out a locus of infection?
And, well, there's
a reason, which
is that there is a rule
that will conclude,
for example, that the abdomen
is a locus of infection
or the pelvis is a locus
of infection of the patient
if you satisfy these criteria.
And so this is a kind of
rudimentary explanation
that comes directly
out of the fact
that these are
rule-based systems
and so you can just
play back the rules.
One of the things I
like is you can also
ask freeform questions.
1975, the natural language
processing was not so good.
And so this worked
about one time in five.
But you could walk up to
it and type some question.
And for example, do you
ever prescribe carbenicillin
for pseudomonas infections?
And it says, well,
there are three rules
in my database of rules that
would conclude something
relevant to that question.
So which one do you want to see?
And if you say, I
want to see rule 64,
it says, well, that
rule says if it's
known with certainty that
the organism is a pseudomonas
and the drug under
consideration is gentamicin,
then a more appropriate
therapy would
be a combination of
gentamicin and carbenicillin.
Again, this is medical
knowledge as of 1975.
But my guess is the
real underlying reason
is that there probably
were pseudomonas
that were resistant by
that point, to gentamicin,
and so they used a
combination therapy.
Now, notice, by the way, that
this explanation capability
does not tell you that, right?
Because it doesn't actually
understand the rationale
behind these individual rules.
And at the time there was
also research, for example,
by one of my students on how
to do a better job of that
by encoding not only the
rules or the patterns,
but also the rationale behind
them so that the explanations
could be more sensible.
OK.
Well, the granddaddy of the
standard just-so story approach
to explanation of complex models
today comes from this paper
and a system called LIME--
Locally Interpretable
Model-agnostic Explanations.
And just to give
you an illustration,
you have some complicated
model and it's
trying to explain why the
doctor or the human being
made a certain decision,
or why the model made
a certain decision.
And so it says, well,
here are the data
we have about the patient.
We know that the
patient is sneezing.
And we know their weight
and their headache
and their age and the fact
that they have no fatigue.
And so the explainer
says, well, why
did the model decide
this patient has the flu?
Well, positives are
sneeze and headache.
And a negative is no fatigue.
So it goes into this
complicated model
and it says, well, I can't
explain all the numerology that
happens in that neural
network or Bayesian network
or whatever network it's using.
But I can specify that
it looks like these
are the most important positive
and negative contributors.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this
for notes only,
or it's for all types of data?
PROFESSOR: I'll show you some
other kind of data in a minute.
I think they originally
worked it out for notes,
but it was also used for
images and other kinds of data,
as well.
OK.
And the argument they make
is that this approach also
helps to detect data
leakage, for example
in one of their experiments,
the headers of the data had
information in them that
that correlated highly
with the result.
I think there-- I can't
remember if it was these guys,
but somebody was assigning
study IDs to each case.
And they did it a stupid way
so that all the small numbers
corresponded to people who had
the disease and the big numbers
corresponded to the
people who didn't.
And of course, the most
parsimonious predictive model
just used the ID number
and said, OK, I got it.
So this would help
you identify that,
because if you see that the
best predictor is the ID number,
then you would say, hmm,
there's something a little fishy
going on here.
Well-- so here's an example
where this kind of capability
is very useful.
So this was another--
this was from a newsgroup.
And they were trying to
decide whether a post was
about Christianity or atheism.
Now, look at these two models.
So there's algorithm
1 and algorithm 2
or model 1 and model 2.
And when you explain
a particular case
about using model 1, it
says, while the words
that I consider important
are God, mean, anyone, this,
Koresh, and through--
does anybody remember
who David Koresh was?
He was some cult leader who--
I can't remember if he killed
a bunch of people or bad things
happened.
Oh, I think he was
the guy in Waco, Texas
that the FBI and the ATF went
in and set their place on fire
and a whole bunch
of people died.
So the prediction in
this case is atheism.
And you notice that God and
Koresh and Mean are negatives.
And anyone this and
through are positives.
And you go, I don't
know, is that good?
But then you look at
algorithm 2 and you say,
this also made the
correct prediction,
which is that this particular
article is about atheism.
But the positives were
the word by and in,
not terribly specific.
And the negatives
were things like NNTP.
You know what that is?
That's the Network
Time Protocol.
It's some technical thing,
and posting and host.
So this is probably
like metadata
that got into the header of
the articles or something.
So it happened
that in this case,
algorithm 2 turned out to be
more accurate than algorithm
1 on their held out test data,
but not for any good reason.
And so the
explanation capability
allows you to clue
in on the fact
that even though this thing
is getting the right answers,
it's not for sensible reasons.
OK.
So what would you like
from an explanation?
Well, they say you'd like
it to be interpretable.
So it should provide
qualitative understanding
of the relationship
between the input
variables and the response.
But they also say
that that's going
to depend on the audience.
It requires sparsity for
the George Miller argument
that I was making before.
You can't keep too
many things in mind.
And the features themselves
that you're explaining
must make sense.
So for example, if I say,
well, the reason this
decided that is
because the eigenvector
for the first
principle component
was the following,
that's not going
to mean much to most people.
And then they also say, well,
it ought to have local fidelity.
So it must correspond
to how the model behaves
in the vicinity of the
particular instance
that you're trying to explain.
And their third criterion, which
I think is a little iffier,
is that it must
be model-agnostic.
In other words, you can't
take advantage of anything
you know that is specific
about the structure
of the model, the way you
trained it, anything like that.
It has to be a general
purpose explainer that
works on any kind of
complicated model.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is the
reasoning for that?
PROFESSOR: I think their
reasoning for why they insist
on this is because
they don't want
to have to write a
separate explainer
for each possible model.
So it's much more efficient
if you can get this done.
But I actually question whether
this is always a good idea
or not.
But nevertheless, this is
one of their assumptions.
OK.
So here's the setup
that they use.
They say, all
right, x is a vector
in some D-dimensional space
that defines your original data.
And what we're
going to do in order
to make the data explainable,
in order to make the data,
not the model,
explainable, is we're
going to define a
new set of variables,
x prime, that are
all binary and that
are in some space of
dimension D prime that
is probably lower than D.
So we're simplifying the
data that we're going
to explain about this model.
Then they say, OK, we're
going to build an explanation
model, g, where g is a class
of interpretable models.
So what's an
interpretable model?
Well, they don't
tell you, but they
say, well, examples might be
linear models, additive scores,
decision trees,
falling rule lists,
which we'll see
later in the lecture.
And the domain of
this is this input,
the simplified input data, the
binary variables in D prime
dimensions, and the model
complexity is going to be some
measure of the depth
of the decision tree,
the number of non-zero weights,
and the logistic regression--
the number of clauses in a
falling rule list, et cetera.
So it's some complexity measure.
And you want to
minimize complexity.
So then they say, all
right, the real model,
the hairy, complicated
full-bore model is f.
And that maps the original data
space into some probability.
And for example,
for classification,
f is the probability that x
belongs to a certain class.
And then they also need
a proximity measure.
So they need to
say, we have to have
a way of comparing two cases
and saying how close are they
to each other?
And the reason for that
is because, remember,
they're going to give
you an explanation
of a particular case and the
most relevant things that
will help with that
explanation are
the ones that are near it in
this high dimensional input
space.
So they then define
their loss function
based on the actual
decision algorithm,
based on the simplified one, and
based on the proximity measure.
And they say, well,
the best explanation
is that g which minimizes
this loss function
plus the complexity of g.
Pretty straightforward.
So that's our best model.
Now, the clever
idea here is to say,
instead of using all of the
data that we started with,
what we're going to do
is to sample the data
so that we take more sample
points near the point we're
interested in explaining.
We're going to sample in
the simplified space that
is explainable and
then we'll build
that g model, the explanatory
model, from that sample of data
where we weight by
that proximity function
so the things that are closer
will have a larger influence
on the model that we learn.
And then we recapture the--
sort of the closest point to
this simplified representation.
We can calculate what
its answer should be.
And that becomes the
label for that point.
And so now we train
a simple model
to predict the label that
the complicated model would
have predicted for the
point that we've sampled.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the proximity
measure is [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: It's a distance
function of some sort.
And I'll say more
about it in a minute,
because that's one
of the critiques
of this particular method
has to do with how do you
choose that distance function?
But it's basically a similarity.
So here's a nice, graphical
explanation of what's going on.
Suppose that the actual model--
the decision boundary is between
the blue and the pink regions.
OK.
So it's this god awful, hairy,
complicated decision model.
And we're trying to explain
why this big, red plus wound up
in the pink rather
than in the blue.
So the approach
that they take is
to say, well, let's
sample a bunch of points
weighted by shortest distance.
So we do sample a
few points out here.
But mostly we're sampling
points near the point
that we're interested in.
We then learn a linear
boundary between the positive
and the negative cases.
And that boundary
is an approximation
to the actual boundary in
the more complicated decision
model.
So now we can give
an explanation
just like you saw
before which says, well,
this is some D prime
dimensional space.
And so which variables in
that D prime dimensional space
are the ones that
influence where
you are on one side or another
of this newly computed decision
boundary, and to what extent?
And that becomes
the explanation.
OK?
Nice idea.
So if you apply this to
text classification-- yes?
AUDIENCE: I was just
going to ask if the--
there's a worry that if
explanation is just fictitious,
like, we can understand it?
But is there reason to believe
that we should believe it
if that's really the
true nature of things
that the linear does-- you
know, it would be like,
OK, we know what's
going on here.
But is that even
close to reality?
PROFESSOR: Well,
that's why I called it
a just-so story, right?
Should you believe it?
Well, the engineering
disciplines
have a very long
history of approximating
extremely complicated
phenomena with linear models.
Right?
I mean, I'm in a department
of electrical engineering
and computer science.
And if I talk to my electrical
engineering colleagues,
they know that the world
is insanely complicated.
Nevertheless, most models
in electrical engineering
are linear models.
And they work well
enough that people
are able to build really
complicated things
and have them work.
So that's not a proof.
That's an argument by
history or something.
But it's true.
Linear models are very
powerful, especially when
you limit them to giving
explanations that are local.
Notice that this model is
a very poor approximation
to this decision boundary
or this one, right?
And so it only works to
explain in the neighborhood
of the particular
example that I've chosen.
Right?
But it does work OK there.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
very well there?
[INAUDIBLE] middle of
the red space then the--
PROFESSOR: Well, they did.
So they sample all
over the place.
But remember that that
proximity function
says that this one is less
relevant to predicting
that decision boundary because
it's far away from the point
that I'm interested in.
So that's the magic.
AUDIENCE: But here
they're trying
to explain to the
deep red cross, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And they
picked some point
in the middle of
the red space maybe.
Then all the nearby ones
would be red and [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Well,
but they would--
I mean, suppose they
picked this point, instead.
Then they would sample
around this point
and presumably they would
find this decision boundary
or this one or
something like that
and still be able to come up
with a coherent explanation.
OK, so in the case
of text, you've
seen this example already.
It's pretty simple.
For their proximity function,
they use cosine distance.
So it's a bag of words
model and they just
calculate cosine distance
between different examples
by how much overlap there is
between the words that they use
and the frequency of
words that they use.
And then they choose k--
the number of words to
show just as a preference.
So it's sort of
a hyperparameter.
They say, you know, I'm
interested in looking
at the top five words
or the top 10 words that
are either positively or
negatively an influence
on the decision, but
not the top 10,000
words because I don't know
what to do with 10,000 words.
Now, what's interesting
is you can also
then apply the same idea
to image interpretation.
So here is a dog
playing a guitar.
And they say, how do
we interpret this?
And so this is one of
these labeling tasks where
you'd like to label this
picture as a Labrador or maybe
as an acoustic guitar.
But some reason--
some labels also
decide that it's
an electric guitar.
And so they say, well,
what counts in favor
of or against each of these?
And the approach they take is a
relatively straightforward one.
They say let's
define a super pixel
as a region of pixels
within an image that have
roughly the same intensity.
So if you've ever
used Photoshop,
the magic selection tool
can be adjusted to say,
find a region around this point
where all the intensities are
within some delta of the
point that I've picked.
And so it'll outline some
region of the picture.
And what they do is they
break up the entire image
into these regions.
And then they treat those
as if they were the words
in the words style explanation.
So they say, well, this
looks like an electric guitar
to the algorithm.
And this looks like
an acoustic guitar.
And this looks like a Labrador.
So some of that makes sense.
I mean, you know,
that dog's face
does kind of look like a Lab.
This does look kind of like
part of the body and part
of the fret work of a guitar.
I have no idea
what this stuff is
or why this contributes
to it being a dog.
But such is-- such is the
nature of these models.
But at least it is
telling you why it
believes these various things.
So then the last
thing they do is
to say, well, OK, that
helps you understand
the particular model.
But how do you
convince yourself--
I mean, a particular example
where a model is applied to it.
But how do you convince
yourself that the model itself
is reasonable?
And so they say, well,
the best technique we know
is to show you a
bunch of examples.
But we want those
examples to kind of cover
the gamut of places that
you might be interested in.
And so they say, let's
create this matrix--
an explanation matrix where
these are the cases and these
are the various features, you
know, the top words or the top
pixel elements or
something, and then we'll
fill in the element of
the matrix that tells me
how strongly this feature is
correlated or anti-correlated
with the classification
for that model.
And then it becomes a
kind of set covering
issue of find a set of
models that gives me
the best coverage
of explanations
across that set of features.
And then with that,
I can convince myself
that the model is reasonable.
So they have this thing called
the sub modular pick algorithm.
And you know, probably
if you're interested,
you should read the paper.
But what they're
doing is essentially
doing a kind of greedy
search that says,
what features should
I add in order
to get the best coverage in that
space of features by documents?
And then they did a
bunch of experiments
where they said,
OK, let's compare
the results of
these explanations
of these simplified models
to two sentiment analysis
tasks of 2,000 instances each.
Bag of words as features-- they
compared it to decision trees,
logistic regression,
nearest neighbors,
SVM with the radial
basis function, kernel,
or random forests that use
word to vacuum beddings--
highly non-explainable--
with 1,000 trees and K equal 10.
So they chose 10
features to explain
for each of these models.
They then did a side
calculation that said,
what are the 10 most suggestive
features for each case?
And then they said, does
that covering algorithm
identify those
features correctly?
And so what they show here is
that their method line does
better in every case
than a random sampling--
that's not very surprising--
or a greedy sampling or a
partisan sampling, which
I don't know the details of.
But in any case, there's
what this graph is showing
is that of the
features that they
decided were important
in each of these cases,
they're recovering.
So their recall is up
around 90, 90-plus percent.
So in fact, the algorithm is
identifying the right cases
to give you a broad
coverage across all
the important
features that matter
in classifying these cases.
They then also did a bunch
of human experiments where
they said, OK, we're going
to ask users to choose which
of two classifiers they think
is going to generalize better.
So this is like the picture I
showed you of the Christianity
versus atheism algorithm,
where presumably if you were
a Mechanical Turker and somebody
showed you an algorithm that
has very high accuracy but that
depends on things like finding
the word NNTP in a
classifier for atheism
versus Christianity, you would
say, well, maybe that algorithm
isn't good to
generalize very well,
because it's depending
on something random that
may be correlated with
this particular data set.
But if I try it on a
different data set,
it's unlikely to work.
So that was one of the tasks.
And then they asked them
to identify features
like that that looked bad.
They then ran this Christianity
versus atheism test
and had a separate test set
of about 800 additional web
pages from this website.
The underlying model was
a support vector machine
with RBF kernels trained
on the 20 newsgroup data--
I don't know if you
know that data set,
but it's a well-known,
publicly available data set.
They got 100 Mechanical Turkers
and they said, OK, we're
going to present each
of them six documents
and six features per document in
order to ask them to make this.
And then they did an auxiliary
experiment in which they said,
if you see words that are no
good in this experiment, just
strike them out.
And that will tell us
which of the features
were bad in this method.
And what they found was that
the human subjects choosing
between two
classifiers were pretty
good at figuring out which
was the better classifier.
Now, this is better
by their judgment.
And so they said, OK, this
submodular pick algorithm--
which is the one that I
didn't describe in detail,
but it's this set
covering algorithm--
gives you better results than
a random pick algorithm that
just says pick random features.
Again, not totally surprising.
And the other thing
that's interesting
is if you do the feature
engineering experiment,
it shows that as the Turkers
interacted with the system,
the system became better.
So they started off
with real world accuracy
of just under 60%.
And using the better
of their algorithms,
they reached about 75% after
three rounds of interaction.
So the users could say, I
don't like this feature.
And then the system would
give them better features.
Now, they tried a similar
thing with images.
And so this one
is a little funny.
So they trained a
deliberately lousy classifier
to classify between
wolves and huskies.
This is a famous example.
Also it turns out that huskies
live in Alaska and so--
and wolves-- I guess some wolves
do, but most wolves don't.
And so the data
set on which that--
which was used in that
original problem formulation,
there was an extremely accurate
classifier that was trained.
And when they went to look
to see what it had learned,
basically it had learned
to look for snow.
And if it saw snow in the
picture, it said it's a husky.
And if it didn't see snow in the
picture, it said it's a wolf.
So that turns out to be
pretty accurate for the sample
that they had.
But of course, it's not a very
sophisticated classification
algorithm because
it's possible to put
a wolf in a snowy
picture and it's
possible to have your
Husky indoors with no snow.
And then you're just missing
the boat on this classification.
So these guys built a
particularly bad classifier
by having all wolves
in the training set
had snow in the picture and
none of the huskies did.
And then they presented cases to
graduate students like you guys
with machine
learning backgrounds.
10 balance test predictions.
But they put one ringer
in each category.
So they put in one husky
in snow and one wolf
who was not in snow.
And the comparison was between
pre and post experiment
trust and understanding.
And so before the
experiment, they
said that 10 of the
27 students said
they trusted this bad
model that they trained.
And afterwards, only 3
out of 27 trusted it.
So this is a kind of
sociological experiment
that says, yes, we can
actually change people's minds
about whether a model is
a good or a bad one based
on an experiment.
Before only 12
out of 27 students
mentioned snow as a potential
feature in this classifier,
whereas afterwards
almost everybody did.
So again, this tells you
that the method is providing
some useful information.
Now this paper set off
a lot of work, including
a lot of critiques of the work.
And so this is one particular
one from just a few months ago,
the end of December.
And what these guys say is that
that distance function, which
includes a sigma, which is
sort of the scale of distance
that we're willing to
go, is pretty arbitrary.
In the experiments that
the original authors did,
they set that distance
to 75% of the square root
of the dimensionality
of the data set.
And you go, OK.
I mean, that's a number.
But it's not obvious
that that's the best
number or the right number.
And so these guys
argue that it's
important to tune the
size of the neighborhood
according to how far z,
the point that you're
trying to explain,
is from the boundary.
So if it's close
to the boundary,
then you ought to
take a smaller region
for your proximity measure.
And if it's far
from the boundary,
this addresses the
question you guys
were asking about
what happens if you
pick a point in the middle.
And so they show
some nice examples
of places where, for instance,
if you compare this explaining
this green point, you get
a nice green line that
follows the local boundary.
But explaining the
blue point, which
is close to a corner of the
actual decision boundary,
you got a line that's not very
different from the green one.
And similarly for the red point.
And so they say,
well, we really need
to work on that
distance function.
And so they come
up with a method
that they call LEAFAGE, which
basically says, remember,
what LINE did is it
sampled nonexistent cases,
simplified nonexistent cases.
But here they're going
to sample existing cases.
So they're going to
learn from the training--
the original training set.
But they're going to sample
it by proximity to the example
that they're trying to explain.
And they argue that this is a
good idea because, for example,
in law, the notion
of precedent is
that you get to argue that this
case is very similar to some
previously decided
case, and therefore it
should be decided the same way.
I mean, Supreme Court arguments
are always all about that.
Lower court arguments
are sometimes
more driven by what
the law actually says.
But case law has been well
established in British law,
and then by inheritance
in American law
for many, many centuries.
So they say, well,
case-based reasoning normally
involves retrieving
a similar case,
adapting it, and then learning
that as a new precedent.
And they also argue for
contrastive justification,
which is not only why
did you choose x, but why
did you choose x
rather than y as giving
a more satisfying
and a more insightful
explanation of how
some model is working?
So they say, OK, similar setup.
f solves the
classification problem
where x is the data and y
is some binary classifier,
you know 0, 1, if you like.
The training set
is a bunch of x's.
y sub true is the actual
answer. y predicted
is what f predicts on that x.
And to explain f of z equals
some particular outcome,
you can define the
allies of a case
as ones that come up
with the same answer.
And you can define
the enemies as one
that wants to come up
with a different answer.
So now you're going to sample
both the allies and the enemies
according to a new
distance function.
And the intuition they
had is that the reason
that the distance function
in the original line work
wasn't working very
well is because it
was a spherical
distance function
in n dimensional space.
And so they're going
to bias it by saying
that the distance,
this b, is going
to be some combination
of the difference
in the linear predictions
plus the difference in the two
points.
And so the contour
lines of the first term
are these circular
contour lines.
This is what lime was doing.
The contour lines
of the second term
are these linear gradients.
And they add them to get
sort of oval-shaped things.
And this is what gives
you that desired feature
of being more sensitive
to how close this point is
to the decision boundary.
Again, there are a lot of
relatively hairy details, which
I'm going to elide
in the class today.
But they're definitely
in the paper.
So they also did a user study
on some very simple prediction
models.
So this was how much is your
house worth based on things
like how big is it and
what year was it built in
and what's some subjective
quality judgment of it?
And so what they
show is that you
can find examples that are
the allies and the enemies
of this house in order
to do the prediction.
So then they apply
their algorithm.
And it works.
It gives you better answers.
I'll have to go find
that slide somewhere.
All right.
So that's all I'm going to
say about this idea of using
simplified models in
the local neighborhood
of individual cases in
order to explain something.
I wanted to talk about
two other topics.
So this was a paper
by some of my students
recently in which they're
looking at medical images
and trying to generate
radiology reports
from those medical images.
I mean, you know,
machine learning
can solve all problems.
I give you a
collection of images
and a collection of
radiology reports,
should be straightforward to
build a model that now takes
new radiological
images and produces
new radiology reports that are
understandable, accurate, et
cetera.
I'm joking, of course.
But the approach they took
was kind of interesting.
So they've taken a
standard image decoder.
And then before
the pooling layer,
they take essentially an
image embedding from the next
to last layer of this
image encoding algorithm.
And then they feed that
into a word decoder and word
generator.
And the idea is
to get things that
appear in the image that
correspond to words that appear
in the report to wind up in
the same place in the embedding
space.
And so again, there's
a lot of hair.
It's an LSDM based encoder.
And it's modeled as
a sentence decoder.
And within that, there
is a word decoder,
and then there's a generator
that generates these reports.
And it uses
reinforcement learning.
And you know, tons of hair.
But here's what I wanted to
show you, which is interesting.
So the encoder takes a bunch
of spatial image features.
The sentence decoder uses these
image features in addition
to the linguistic features,
the word embeddings that
are fed into it.
And then for ground
truth annotation,
they also use a remote
annotation method, which
is this chexpert program, which
is a rule-based program out
of Stanford that reads
radiology reports
and identifies features in
the report that it thinks
are important and correct.
So it's not always
correct, of course.
But that's used in order
to guide the generator.
So here's an example.
So this is an image of a
chest and the ground truth--
so this is the actual
radiology report--
says cardiomegalia is moderate.
Bibasilar atelectasis is mild.
There's no pneumothoraxal
or cervical spinal
fusion is partially visualized.
Healed right rib fractures
are incidentally noted.
By the way, I've stared at
hundreds of radiological images
like this.
I could never figure out
that this image says that.
But that's why radiologists
train for many, many years
to become good at this stuff.
So there was a
previous program done
by others called TieNet which
generates the following report.
It says AP portable
upright view of the chest.
There's no call no focal
consolidation, effusion,
or pneumothorax.
The cardio mediastinal
silhouette is normal.
Imaged osseous
structures are intact.
So if you compare
this to that, you
say, well, if the cardio
mediastinal silhouette
is normal, then where would
the lower cervical spinal
fusion, being partially
visualized, because that's
along the middle.
And so these are not
quite consistent.
So the system that
these students built
says there's mild enlargement
of the cardiac silhouette.
There is no pleural
effusion or pneumothorax.
And there's no acute
osseous abnormalities.
So it also missed the
healed right rib fractures
that were incidentally noted.
But anyway, it's-- you know,
the remarkable thing about
a singing dog is not how well
it sings but the fact that it
sings at all.
And the reason I
included this work
is not to convince
you that this is
going to replace
radiologists anytime soon,
but that it had an interesting
explanation facility.
And the explanation
facility uses
attention, which is
part of its model,
to say, hey, when we
reach some conclusion,
we can point back
into the image and say
what part of the
image corresponds
to that part of the conclusion.
And so this is
pretty interesting.
You say in upright and lateral
views of the chest in red,
well, that's kind
of the chest in red.
There's moderate cardiomegaly,
so here the green
certainly shows you
where your heart is.
OK.
About there and a
little bit to the left.
And there's no pleural
effusion or pneumothorax.
This one is kind of funny.
That's the blue region.
So how do you show me that
there isn't something?
And we were surprised,
actually, the way
it showed us that
there isn't something
is to highlight everything
outside of anything
that you might be
interested in, which
is not exactly convincing that
there's no pleural effusion.
And here's another example.
There is no relevant change,
tracheostomy tube in place,
so that roughly is
showing a little too wide.
But it's showing roughly where
a tracheostomy tube might be.
Bilateral pleural effusion
and compressive atelectasis.
Atelectasis is when your
lung tissues stick together.
And so that does often happen
in the lower part of the lung.
And again, the negative
shows you everything
that's not part of the action.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No.
It's trying to predict
the whole model--
the whole node.
AUDIENCE: And it's not easier to
have, like, one node for, like,
each [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But these guys were ambitious.
You know, they-- what was it?
Jeff Hinton said a few
years ago that he wouldn't
want his children to
become radiologists
because that field is going
to be replaced by computers.
I think that was a stupid
thing to say, especially
when you look at the
state of the art of how
well these things work.
But if that were true,
then you would, in fact,
want something that is able
to produce an entire radiology
report.
So the motivation is there.
Now, after this
work was done, we
ran into this interesting paper
from Northeastern, which says--
but listen guys-- attention
is not explanation.
OK.
So attention is
clearly a mechanism
that's very useful in all kinds
of machine learning methods.
But you shouldn't confuse
it with an explanation.
So they say, well, assumption--
it's the assumption
that the input units are
accorded high attention-- that
are accorded high
attention weights are
responsible for
the model outputs.
And that may not be true.
And so what they did is they
did a bunch of experiments
where they studied
the correlation
between the attention weights
and the gradients of the model
parameters to see whether,
in fact, the words that
had high attention
were the ones that
were most decisive in making
a decision in the model.
And they found that the
evidence that correlation
between intuitive feature
importance measures, including
gradient and feature
erasure approaches-- so this
is ablation studies and learn
detention weights is weak.
And so they did a
bunch of experiments.
There are a lot of controversies
about this particular study.
But what you find is that if
you calculate the concordance,
you know, on different data
sets using different models,
you see that, for example, the
concordance is not very high.
It's less than a half
for this data set.
And you know, some
of it below 0,
so the opposite
for this data set.
Interestingly,
things like diabetes,
which come from the mimic
data, have narrower bounds
than some of the others.
So they seem to have a more
definitive conclusion, at least
for the study.
OK.
Let me finish off by talking
about the opposite idea.
So rather than building
a complicated model
and then trying to
explain it in simple ways,
what if we just
built a simple model?
And Cynthia Rudin,
who's now at Duke,
used to be at the
Sloan School at MIT,
has been championing
this idea for many years.
And so she has come up with
a bunch of different ideas
for how to build
simple models that
trade off maybe a little
bit of accuracy in order
to be explainable.
And one of her favorites is
this thing called a falling rule
list.
So this is an example for a
mammographic mass data set.
So it says, if some lump
has an irregular shape
and the patient is
over 60 years old,
then there's an 85%
chance of malignancy risk,
and there are 230 cases
in which that happened.
If this is not the case,
then if the lump has
the speculated margin--
so it has little spikes
coming out of it--
and the patient is
over 45, then there's
a 78% chance of malignancy.
And otherwise, if the margin is
kind of fuzzy, the edge of it
is kind of fuzzy, and
the patient is over 60,
then there's a 69% chance.
And if it has an
irregular shape,
then there's a 63% chance.
And if it's lobular and
the density is high,
then there's a 39% chance.
And if it's round and
the patient is over 60,
then there's a 26% chance.
Otherwise, there's a 10% chance.
And the argument is that that
description of the model,
of the decision-making
model, is simple enough
that even doctors
can understand it.
You're supposed to laugh.
Now, there are
still some problems.
So one of them is--
notice some of these
are age greater than
60, age greater than 45,
age greater than 60.
It's not quite obvious what
categories that's defining.
And in principle, it
could be different ages
in different ones.
But here's how they build it.
So this is a very
simple model that's
built by a very
complicated process.
So the simple model is the
one I've just showed you.
There's a Bayesian approach, a
Bayesian generative approach,
where they have a bunch of hyper
parameters, falling rule list
parameters, theta--
they calculate a
likelihood, which
is given a particular
theta, how likely
are you to get the answers that
are actually in your data given
the model that you generate?
And they start with a
possible set of if clauses.
So they do frequent
clause mining
to say what conditions,
what binary conditions occur
frequently together
in the database.
And those are the
only ones they're
going to consider
because, of course,
the number of possible
clauses is vast
and they don't want to have
to iterate through those.
And then for each set
of-- for each clause,
they calculate a
risk score which
is generated by a
probability distribution
under the constraint that the
risk score for the next clause
is lower or equal to the risk
score for the previous clause.
There are lots of details.
So there is this frequent
itemset mining algorithm.
It turns out that
choosing r sub l
to be the logs of
products of real numbers
is an important step
in order to guarantee
that monotonicity
constraint in a simple way.
l, the number of
clauses, is drawn
from a Poisson distribution.
And you give it a
kind of scale that
says roughly how many
clauses would you
be willing to tolerate in
your following rule list?
And then there's a lot
of computational hair
where they do--
they get mean a posteriori
probability estimation
by using a simulated
annealing algorithm.
So they basically
generate some clauses
and then they use swap, replace,
add, and delete operators
in order to try
different variations.
And they're doing hill
climbing in that space.
There's also some
Gibbs sampling,
because once you have
one of these models,
simply calculating how accurate
it is is not straightforward.
There's not a closed
form way of doing it.
And so they're doing sampling in
order to try to generate that.
So it's a bunch of hair.
And again, the paper
describes it all.
But what's interesting is
that on a 30 day hospital
readmission data set with
about 8,000 patients,
they used about 34 features,
like impaired mental status,
difficult behavior, chronic
pain, feels unsafe, et cetera.
They mind rules or clauses
with support more than 5%
of the database and no
more than two conditions.
They set the expected
length of the decision list
to be eight clauses.
And then they compared
the decision model
they got to SVM's random
force logistic regression
cart and an inductive
logic programming approach.
And shockingly to
me, their method--
the following rule list method--
got an AUC of about 0.8, whereas
all the others did like 0.79,
0.75 logistic
regression, as usual
outperformed the one
they got slightly.
Right?
But this is interesting,
because their argument
is that this
representation of the model
is much more easy to understand
than even a logistic regression
model for most human users.
And also, if you look at--
these are just various runs
and the different models.
And their model has a
pretty decent AUC up here.
I think the green one is
the logistic regression one.
And it's slightly better because
it outperforms their best model
in the region of low false
positive rates, which may
be where you want to operate.
So that may actually
be a better model.
So here's their
readmission rule list.
And it says if the
patient has bed sores
and has a history of not
showing up for appointments,
then there's a 33%
probability that they'll
be readmitted within 30 days.
If-- I think some note says
poor prognosis and maximum care,
et cetera.
So this is the result
that they came up with.
Now, by the way, we've talked
a little bit about 30 day
readmission predictions.
And getting over about 70%
is not bad in that domain
because it's just not that
easily predictable who's
going to wind up back in
the hospital within 30 days.
So these models are
actually doing quite well,
and certainly understandable
in these terms.
They also tried on a
variety of University
of California-Irvine
machine learning data sets.
These are just random
public data sets.
And they tried building
these falling rule
list models to make predictions.
And what you see is that
the AUCs are pretty good.
So on the spam
detection data set,
their system gets about 91.
Logistic regression,
again, gets 97.
So you know, part of the
unfortunate lesson that we
teach in almost every
example in this class
is that simple models
like logistic regression
often do quite well.
But remember, here they're
optimizing for explainability
rather than for getting
the right answer.
So they're willing to sacrifice
some accuracy in their model
in order to develop
a result that
is easy to explain to people.
So again, there are many
variations on this type of work
where people have different
notions of what counts
as a simple, explainable model.
But that's a very
different approach
than the LIME approach, which
says build the hairy model
and then produce local
explanations for why
it makes certain decisions
on particular cases.
All right.
I think that's all I'm going
to say about explainability.
This is a very hot
topic at the moment,
and so there are lots of papers.
I think there's-- I just
saw a call for a conference
on explainable machine
learning models.
So there's more and
more work in this area.
So with that, we come to
the end of our course.
And I just wanted--
I just went through the front
page of the course website
and listed all the topics.
So we've covered quite
a lot of stuff, right?
You know, what makes
health care different?
And we talked about what
clinical care is all about
and what clinical data is
like and risk stratification,
survival modeling,
physiological time series, how
to interpret clinical text
in a couple of lectures,
translating technology
into the clinic.
The italicized ones
were guest lectures, so
machine learning for
cardiology and machine
learning for
differential diagnosis,
machine learning for
pathology, for mammography.
David gave a couple of
lectures on causal inference
and reinforcement learning
where David and a guest--
which I didn't note here--
disease progression
and sub typing.
We talked about
precision medicine
and the role of genetics,
automated clinical workflows,
the lecture on regulation,
and then recently fairness,
robustness to data set
shift, and interpretability.
So that's quite a lot.
I think we're-- we the staff are
pretty happy with how the class
has gone.
It was our first time as
this crew teaching it.
And we hope to do it again.
I can't stop without giving
an immense vote of gratitude
to Irene and Willy,
without whom we
would have been totally sunk.
[APPLAUSE]
And I also want to acknowledge
David's vision in putting
this course together.
He taught a sort of half-size
version of a class like this
a couple of years
ago and thought
that it would be a good idea to
expand it into a full semester
regular course and got me
on board to work with him.
And I want to thank you
all for your hard work.
And I'm looking forward to--